hi i'm nick kroll and i voice maury the
hormone monster hi i'm eddie bryant and
i'm emmy the love bug hi i'm brandon
kyle goodman and i'm walter the love bug
hello i'm randall park and i play
pete the logic rock and we are going to
take a buzzfeed quiz to let you know
which human resources character we are
how's that buzzfeed did i do it right
[Music]
first how would your bffs describe you
loyal clever bold
vibrant ambitious or sincere i just have
to say randall the way you say bffs
makes you sound very old
how did i say how did i say
dfpfs like it was
i've never heard something more dad
vibes than the way you just said bffs i
did not realize i was saying it that way
but i'm old you're mature i would say
i'm famously sincere i'm known for this
mine is a lawyer yeah yeah i think real
too i like wanted to say loyal but i
feel like my friends are like you're not
that
[Laughter]
i went with clever the next one is
choose a celebrity for your character to
work with and the options are zendaya
chris evans beyonce
john malooney i think is how you
pronounce that name is that right john
maloney michelle obama and brad pitt
that's quite the stack that's the crew i
know so we got love bugs we got logic
rocks and we got a hormone monster it's
claimed on the show that michelle and
barack obama were who were they clients
of who they are
sonya the love bug worked with michelle
and she's always dropping that knowledge
so we'll leave i'll leave that for her
is it weird to say that i would be
psyched to be zendaya's hormone monster
i think that's good yeah oh yeah she's
having a moment right now so you know
things are going good i know well i
would just encourage her to keep tearing
little tom holland apart you know
i think i'll go with brad pitt because
i'm like what's up babe
what's up what's love you know are you
like yeah you're like what what is love
what is love for brad pitt right now
yeah it's between chris evans and
beyonce and i feel like that's an
obvious choice right beyonce yeah
i'm sorry
sorry mr
because as i understand he just had a a
baby and i think you know when you have
a baby you could use
some logical thinking because it's a
stressful time great hey who's ready for
the next one
who's a character to trust with a secret
is it mona the hormone monstrous kitty
the depression kitty rick the hormone
monster tito the anxiety mosquito rhino
the shame wizard or rochelle the love
bug trust with a secret
hmm as the the person who voices rick
the hormone monster i would not trust
him with a secret oh you know i might
because he wouldn't remember it yeah
yeah so i'm going to trust rick with the
hormone monster with a secret because
you can if it's truly a vault it will
not escape i'm going to trust rochelle
the love bug because you know emmy and
rochelle are best friends on the show i
feel that
it's a gorgeous fit yeah i'm gonna i'm
gonna trust rochelle as well i'm in love
with her
and uh
oh am i allowed to say that i think so
i'm i mean you're it's more of a spoiler
that you randall park are in love with
rochelle the love
that's the real
i am i am in love with rochelle de love
but i'm picking rochelle i'm also gonna
pick rochelle three for rochelle i'm
just gonna put it out there rick's
trustworthy
yeah yeah we'll keep that i'll read the
next
you do you baby you do you
this gives me anxiety choose a song to
belt out karaoke
okay i want to dance with somebody by
whitney houston truth hurts by lizzo
dancing queen by abba umbrella by
rihanna watermelon sugar by harry styles
man i feel like a woman by shania twain
these are good picks i feel like you
guys would be good at karaoke oh no it
shakes me to my core
me too more than anything like doing it
and hearing it
like cringing i have like a mental
breakdown where i'm like i'm already an
actor like get off stage like i i feel
guilty like i shouldn't be doing it but
nevertheless i will choose man i feel
like a woman
never the love i i'm gonna choose i want
to dance with somebody by whitney
houston i have sung that at karaoke
before i've sung
at karaoke so i'm gonna go with umbrella
by rihanna i will choose truth hurts by
lizzo because i'm not a great singer but
i'm a very talented flautist so i
usually bring a flute with me to all
karaoke events
so i'll i'll mainly focus on that and
finally okay sorry
i didn't know i was trying to take it
out of 80. i didn't want to take an
intro away from you i feel terrible now
i don't want to do i don't want to be
here
[Laughter]
i really want to do this intro can i do
it yes yes
and finally choose something important
from human resources becca's new baby
the need demons nadia's berkeley
acceptance the chugger
sensitivity training yara's time
distortion this is one of the more no
offense buzzfeed bizarre things to try
to wrap one's head around
do something important important human
resources so
becca's new baby i had a baby in the
last year so i i was able to personally
identify very much with that story i
will also say yara's time distortion
which is about an older woman's like uh
issues with dementia and and brandon
kyle goodman is as her love bug walter
is one of my favorite
beautiful stories yes me too i'm gonna
say yara's time distortion because uh i
cried reading that i mean that's how you
measure importance right how much you
cry yes
yeah yeah
i clicked nadia's berkeley acceptance oh
wow but that was an accident but it
happened already so
well that's what we're going to do that
was what the universe wanted it was yeah
that's what's important to the universe
i'll choose the chugger because i really
like the chugger that's a people like an
emmy story the real that's like a real
classic like office
workplace kind of storyline and there's
nothing more important to you than
office workplace story lines lady i know
that i'm known for this in sincerity
that's all i got
which human racers character are you i'm
emmy the love bug
yes because you're just like emmy you're
funny sarcastic and always trying your
best like emmy it takes you a little
while to open up to new people but once
you do you become their friend for life
you're a glass half empty kind of person
who sometimes needs reminding that
you're capable of so many great things
i am walter the lover oh
yeah
love bugs walter the love bug you're
just like walter you're kind hearted
enthusiastic and just a little bit zany
i am zany
you tend to brighten every room you walk
into and people truly cannot get enough
of your positive energy you feel deeply
and you have all the passion in the
world nice
that's actually what i've heard all of
your bffs
say about it
i'm keep the logic rock
i like how we're all getting each other
okay you're just like pete you're
resourceful trustworthy and just a
little bit of a nerd like pete you're
the realistic one of the bunch and
always tell it like it is people admire
your blunt honesty because they know
they can trust you above anyone else
that's what everyone always says about
you that and that in your sincerity
i'm blunt and sincere and i love office
storylines
did you guys talk to 80 yeah she told it
like it was again
i don't know what this says about me but
i got mori the hormone monster you're
just like mori you're clever loyal and
pretty damn cool tbh like mori you love
to have a good time especially when it's
with your closest friends i think that
means that i want to [ __ ] my friends
you crave a good adventure and people
often turn to you and they need cheering
up that's true that's just true
you guys all do you guys call me every
day when you're down in the dumps and
i'm there for you that's right every day
another perfect buzzfeed quiz
thank you so much buzzfeed i couldn't be
more thankful to you buzzfeed for having
us take this quiz please watch human
resources on netflix but also go check
out buzzfeed it's a great site there's
great stuff on there
great way to spend your day now we're
going to do the end just like that
we're all samantha on a text chain
[Laughter]
you are deaf steve what's up would you
say marina
yes good morning